hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna do some design and dev work on a
home page for our react site and we're
using material design and we have a
framework called material UI that we're
using to build things out so we're gonna
be working with that and all the codes
available there's a link in the
description and I thought I'd start out
today by giving a very brief overview of
the project since we haven't done an
overview for a while or on this is the
thirty-fifth
stream I believe so we're pretty far
into this project and I know some of you
are kind of jumping in in the middle so
let me give just a really quick
breakdown and that'll give everybody a
chance to join in as well if they're
just getting their notifications that
we've gone live so we have a react site
that we build with next j/s primarily we
went with next j/s because it offers
very easy server-side rendering we have
all our content housed in a wordpress
installation so that means it's a my
sequel database on WordPress we have the
WP graph QL plug-in and that allows us
to pull data from that my sequel
database with graph QL and bring it into
our react application so whenever we
grab data we're almost exclusively using
graph QL the reason we went with
WordPress is because it's very easy for
people who don't really know a lot about
code to input content so that's why we
went with that it's also very stable and
has a large user base so we made a
custom plugin to
of us a lot of different post types and
taxonomies if you're not familiar with
WordPress you know terminology and
things it's just you know different ways
for us to house our data and to make it
very simple for people who are managing
content to know where to put the data
and that's that's it I mean that that's
pretty much the overview of where we're
at we've had some other steps along the
way we've had to migrate some data but
overall that's the structure of of the
project so far so right now I'm at the
point in the project where I need to
make it look nice enough to present it
to some people here at the university
that I work for so I'd like to have that
presentable looking by tomorrow morning
and then I'll have a meeting my first of
several meetings where I get to display
this so that's where we're at right now
if anyone has any questions about how we
set anything up let me know I could at
least point you to the stream where we
set that up so you can watch the setup
process yourself or I can you know take
a few minutes and explain it let's see
just want to say hi and read through a
little bit in the live chat now before
we start to see if there's anything I
should address now okay great
so Niki has some advice for my
presentations about is just to talk
about its value to the visitors not only
its features
alright that's that's really good advice
if anyone has any advice for me when I
go to present the site please let me
know I'm gonna be talking to different
groups so one group is going to be
people that are like in charge of the
university and another group is gonna be
people who are primarily they interact
with the students they're in charge of
the student life Department I think I
might do I don't think I'm gonna meet
with faculty members I think I'm gonna
do like a live stream for faculty
members we're gonna call it a webinar
because that's more like with their
terminology that they're used to so
that's depending on the group I may
focus a little bit more on different
features I even thought about kind of
changing some of the content we have on
the homepage for different groups but I
don't want to get too far ahead of
myself we still have some work to do
right now so let me switch over so that
you all can see what I'm saying on on
one of my screens here so here's the
code let me just catch you up on what
I've done I've created this list card
component which we we did a lot of the
styling for that yesterday but I've
split it out into a component yeah this
is too small make it a little bigger
okay and let me try to get as much out
of the way as we can so here's the new
component and all the code is up to date
in in github so if you click the link
below you'll be able to see it and you
can also see the website if I start this
and Rock server you'll be able to check
out the website on your own computer
there it is so if you can view the live
chat there's a link now in the live chat
to check out this site unfortunately if
you're watching later on this and Rock
server probably won't be running so you
won't have access to it otherwise I
would put the link in the description as
well and I can for those of you who
can't see the site right now I'm gonna
pull this over and I we're primarily
doing the mobile view of the site right
now so I've been kind of showing it at
this view and this is a very small phone
so the odds of somebody having a phone
like this are low but I really want to
make sure it looks all right on all
different devices so you may notice some
differences I'll try to point them out
as I go through so we still have the the
cute little dog as our background
picture which we need to get rid of that
I keep putting it off because I'm hoping
that someone else in my department will
send me a picture that they really think
would work it hasn't happened yet but
I'd rather not spend a lot of time going
through pictures because they I can
spend a lot of time on that so one thing
that I did do is I changed the way we're
bringing in YouTube embeds so before
material.you I already has a media card
component where you could put in the URL
that you want to use and what component
you want to use in our case we were
passing in as a prop iframe and we were
also passing in the source so that was
okay but the problem was it was acting
like we were hovering the entire time so
if you see it's not letting me do it
here for some reason when I inspect this
with dev tools it doesn't have the same
hover effect but anyway when you hover
the YouTube button is entirely red
whereas normally it's let me refresh
can see this normally again so oh well
now it's doing it for some reason I keep
getting this always red button maybe
it's because it's mobile sorry I think
that's the issue yeah okay so on mobile
we can't really do anything about it but
when we have more of a desktop view we
have this semi-transparent button and
then it only goes red when you hover so
for some reason when we use the material
UI component like it was always red I
couldn't get it to change so now I just
have a card where I directly put an
iframe in it works and it doesn't really
add anything to the code so I think it's
fine but you may see a difference in the
code I would switch it back here I've
changed out so a lot of the silly filler
content that I had in there I'm gonna
have to take out so I'm starting to put
in like real facts we built this card
out before so here's what I came up with
for that list component now I know this
all probably looks really small on your
screen so I encourage you to use that
anger out link if you can but anyway so
we have the events list here we have
some data and we have some options so if
you don't pass in an image then it goes
full width like this which I think works
better when you have more content also
you don't have to pass in the secondary
text if you don't want to so you just
have you should kind of show on a few of
the options that we have here
I'm still thinking that I'd like to
display the date of these events
somewhere but I also think it's time for
me to move on and get this page looking
like it's completed and then if I have
time I can go back and add in some
details so the rest I do still have some
of those that filler content in here so
today what I'd like to do is go
and maybe make some real content for
some of these pieces and also work on
see some of the details so as we go
through I'll point out some of the
details that I still don't like about
how this looks and and we'll fix those
all right okay so that's what we started
I'm going to start with Pomodoro clock
so I may reset this so I'd like to break
up the work in Pomodoro sessions so
we're going to do 25 minutes of code and
then I'll take a five-minute break I'll
go back to the live chat oh I got to say
this out loud though Ruben says how is
it possible to be so handsome I I'm
gonna assume that that was directed
towards me and that I am the one that is
so handsome so I don't know I you could
thank the person that cuts my hair also
my mom and dad they probably had
something to do with the handsomeness
I'm just I'm just messing around
I'm sure that was probably a joke but it
still feels good to get comments like
that so thank you okay so let's get into
some of the code first off let's put in
a little bit more content and I'm gonna
run some ideas by you about you know
kind of what I'm thinking we have right
now especially in this view it's just a
lot of content you know like right in a
row it kind of works but I'm I don't
know if my boss will like this idea or
not but I'm thinking about maybe we can
split up the content into some sections
I'm
I don't know I'm on the fence about that
one and I'm not sure that's something I
can get done before a presentation but
it seems to me like sections might help
break things up a little bit and make
more sense of this content so as we're
going through if you see some I don't
know some pattern to things where you
think a section of it might be good let
me know I know that's pretty vague I
just had the idea you know an hour or
two ago so I'm still kind of thinking
about it as well but all right one
detail that I really like to change that
keeps bothering me so let's just change
it right now is I really want this logo
to be centered I don't know that bothers
anybody else but on a larger screen I
think it looks fine to be over here but
when it's this small it it's close
enough to the center that it looks weird
let me know if you disagree with that
but I just think it it looks like it's
supposed to be centered but it's
off-center to me only when it's this
small though so first thing I'm going to
do is just inspect this in dev tools
which if you are viewing this through
that and Rock link you should be able to
do this as well and so let's see what
the container is this will help to
figure out mm-hmm all right I don't like
that so the container that's large
enough to actually you make this go to
the middle is this container here this
div but the div also contains this
button I don't want the button to be
centered so let's see what we can do
alright let's check out how this really
is in the component right because
material UI is changing these into some
dips but let's see what the the
component actually looks like so this is
probably going to be in our app bar
let's see the app over here Wow the app
bar is quite a large component I haven't
done anything with the app bar in a
while so here's our logo and let's see
is this the making sure we should have
two places with a logo one of them is
going to be the drawer so but I think we
have that in a separate component
interesting that's really interesting
how we did that
hmm
I can i I'm looking at this I you you
all can probably see already but I'm
kind of puzzled looking at this that I
did it this way so I probably copied
over an example from the material UI
documentation which had typography as an
element in the app bar and it was
probably just some text and then what I
did instead of replacing typography with
another element I just added this image
element inside of the typography element
I don't know that that's this may be a
waste of of this element here so I'm
gonna try to do a little bit let's let's
say refactoring here and maybe clean
this up and see what happens so what I'd
like to do is let's see what with this
classes flex is going right now to see
if we should keep it or we can get rid
of it so let's find flex okay so it's
just saying flex one for that all right
let's
and then you button
this is classes two column one class I
wonder if we should have two different
structures one for small screen and one
for a large screen
I see some more of you saying hi in the
live chat hey thanks for watching thanks
for joining in okay so here was my
thought if I go changing this it's not
only going to change for the mobile view
it's going to change for the desktop
view I don't want the desktop view to
change so I need to not just start
deleting things ideally what I would be
able to do is just take one of these
classes like let's take a look at the
header image class for an example and
use a media query or the the mature UI
version of a media query which I'll show
you an example in just a second and just
change the style like that so I I think
that'll be the best way to go for now
even though I really don't like that to
typography element maybe now when is
this close to the presentation isn't the
time for me to be going in and just
trying things and hoping they don't
break and I can't find that header image
there we are okay
that's it huh and they see where where
that was that okay so that actually is
on the image that's iPod Rafi
alright let's go back to dev tools play
around just a little bit I I kind of
think we're gonna have to change the
structure of this if it was just
structured slightly different this
wouldn't be as big of a deal
all right so with so this is the yeah
all right let's try this with so okay so
the problem was these containers weren't
yeah this isn't going to work with this
structure so we can we can set the
alignment to be centered but you see the
the container here is is already
off-center so we're not gonna get it to
be centered exactly with the element
like that
if we took it out of the flow though and
it's just sticky no the snap isn't
sticky and maybe it should be all right
I have an idea
here's my idea and I'm gonna say before
I do it so that you all can stop me if
it's a silly idea alright so number one
I think it makes sense for this knife to
be sticky on mobile because there's a
lot of scrolling going on here it would
be nice to be able to just get to the
menu without having to scroll back up I
I would appreciate that so I think at
the very least on mobile that we should
have a sticky navigation or fixed
navigation whatever you prefer maybe
even on desktop that might be the way to
go but at least on mobile we should do
that secondly if we're going to do a
fixed navigation we could just position
this thing differently so that all right
like potentially we might be able to
just take it out of the flow right now
so we'll see how this works but let's
alright good so I'm getting some
feedback so Nikki says make it thinner
while scrolling it's a personal
preference I dislike all the space that
it consumes okay yeah I I agree with
that I agree so first things first let's
make it sticky and then we can try to
shrink it a little bit I I definitely
think we can shrink it it's there's a
lot of white space happening this logo
could be smaller and still be perfectly
readable so let's do that
a new Java version I would remind me
later I don't even know why I have job
on here I I'm not sure if I actually use
anything that needs it I suspect the
material I probably already has a class
that will make this fixed so let's just
see if we can add that class before I
try to do it on my own or is I know I
have the material ID documentation
already open air we are in at least one
place I probably have it open multiple
places do you ever get to that point on
your desktop that it's faster just to
search just to open a new tab and go to
a website than to try to find what
website what tab like you already have
open with that website in there I said
that really awkwardly hopefully made
sense but that's where I'm at right now
is that I know I have certain websites
open but I just don't know where so I
end up just opening up opening them up
again let's check out the app bar and
let's see fixed awesome so we can do
position what's the difference between
sticky note sticky is not universally
supported and we'll fullback the static
little bit different options just going
to be all right yeah I want to see what
the options are
okay so stickies experimental all right
I remember seeing this before so
stickies for everything you know
interesting and it falls back to static
otherwise let's see what sticky is
supported by so position sticky so edge
supports it
Firefox partially supports it okay not
supported on table supported on thn us
safari supports it all right let's use
to this and sticky because we have
pretty good support yeah I like the
support on this
all right cool if you've never been to
can I use calm before it's very very
useful super-easy one thing I really
like is as soon as you go there your
cursors automatically put right here so
you soon as it loads you can just start
typing and you don't even you know it
just searches as you as you go so really
simple and fast and you would just
immediately know whether or not you know
a specific thing in CSS or JavaScript or
HTML will work also if you're not using
mdn so Mozilla developer Network you
should definitely check it out usually
as way more information than I need but
the examples are super useful so those
are if you only take away two things
from this stream those two things will
be more helpful to you probably than
anything else that I do okay and I know
I'm not keeping up with the live chat
right now in about ten minutes or so I'm
gonna check back in the live chat and
see what what I've been missing and
respond to any questions all right so
let's add that in this app bar it's a
position yeah it was position so instead
of static we're gonna type in sticky
give that a save and see what happens
alright nothing so far maybe I need to
put in some more information what
happened to that did I seriously close
material UI mister now you can see all
my browsing history right temp is from I
did I not close it
Wow ok I don't know what I did with it
easy to get back to the app let's look
at the API sticky
all right maybe we will go to the demos
because it doesn't explain what else I'm
it seems to me like there needs to be
some other indicator of like when is it
supposed to go sticky simply button mmm
alright it looks like none of these are
sticky yeah these are all position
static let me check you're looking for
position fig stickies useful phone and
bars that are down a bit and stick to
the top after you scroll oh that's what
the sticky is then nevermind I feel
silly now okay I was thinking that
sticky would give us something at an
option like the app bar would just yeah
I don't know what I was thinking
thanks sneaky all right let's go to a
position fixed I was just excited to use
something new
I know okay we got to do unexpected but
I should have expected it so our content
now since the app bar is gone has gone
to a fixed position all of our content
has now gone up to the top of the page
so we need you you think material you I
would have already had something to take
that into account let's see
oh whoa
let's check out the layout
[Music]
what's this portal
uh-huh that's I haven't seen that
component before all right let's let's
take a bar and where's our main let's go
back to our layout component and this is
where we bring in the app bar and then
we have everything else falls in this
main component here so if we go up to
classes main right now it's the only
thing we have on there is this flex so
what we want to do then is set a margin
top yeah I guess margin to work and we
want the margin top to be the same
height as the a bar but I'd like them to
always be I want them to always be the
same let's check our app bar component
I'm checking to see if we have a height
set already I guess we don't it's kind
of odd I would have expected that
let's go back here and see okay we do
have this is that root component which
basically is is just a container
component here see what we're getting
our height from so from somewhere in
here then
okay so some of our height at least is
is set here by this icon to 48 pixels
are that makes sense let's see where we
can put height at if I'm confusing you
right now then hold on just it's going
to make a lot of sense once I actually
do it assuming that it works and I think
it'll be easier to see it then for me to
explain it
that's interesting
okay that's pretty cool and interesting
let's see header
okay the way this is set up is not gonna
make it easy to do to change the height
all right let's see you're searching for
a component that when I add a height it
would actually make make a change all
right maybe this is not gonna work out
like the way I wanted to work out all
right so basically we can have it be
fixed and have everything work if we
just put a height of 65 on our root
component
right and what do we do on layout
whatever I did on layout I need to
change okay all right my timer went off
so it's time for me to go to the live
chat but we can see we now have our
fixed app bar and yeah that definitely
needs to be smaller but in any case we
have it fixed now okay we've gotten
deeper and deeper into this whole of
like all I wanted to do is make this
centered and it's now become so much
more complicated all right let me set a
five-minute timer then and I'm gonna
scroll up to the top of the live chat go
down I'm gonna try to get to as many
comments and questions as I can see
Gander 7 says have you seen visual
studio live sharing you can code
collaboratively between visual studio
code and visual studio even even sharing
a session code visual studio comm
alright as the rest of the URL there
okay cool I'll have to check that up I
have not used it yet John says I got
p.m. today
a painting question I answered honestly
then I was destroyed with a horrible
lashing out so Jessie it's nice to come
here where people are civilized oh I'm
really sorry that happened to you
but yeah I'm never gonna lash out at
anyone in Chad even if you said
something that made me really mad
I would I would still try my best to
just be chill about it and I probably
just blocked you if I thought that it
was harming the the experience in the
live chat but anyway I've been trying to
be really chill about everything lately
not in a live chat in particular
obviously in the live chat but just in
general especially with my kids because
they're all little and so been trying to
just be really calm and keep it like a
nice tone of voice with you know even if
I'm mad so anyway this is definitely a
nice calm place to be in so if you're
joining us for the first time you might
not know that but feel free to ask any
questions even no matter how basic you
know you think they are nobody's going
to get mad at you for it or be mean
about it and if they are then if they're
really really mean and they won't stop I
block them if they're mean though I
usually say something you know kind of
politely you know tell people to be nice
let's see Grimlock er says can I ask
which is better for me to study
bootstrap or angular I'm still new okay
well it looks like you did get some
answers already and the answers are
pretty good so Joey says bootstrap and
angular 2 different types of tools and
yeah that's that's a hundred percent
correct so bootstrap is for user
interface so like design it's basically
like a prebuilt design framework that
you can use you know they're their
components angular is that's hard to
explain especially I guess if you're
just starting out yeah but basically the
the easy answer the quick answer is you
can certainly study both at the same
time because they do two different
things you can use bootstrap with
angular you could use it on its own and
the same thing you can use angular on
its own they do different things so if
you'd like to learn them both go ahead
if you want to they're learn one or the
other that's fine but you you don't use
them for the same thing if you want me
to go more in-depth into the differences
please let me know I can do that but I
don't want to spend too much time going
to the question if if no one's
interested in it
ah no says I agree with the fixed
navigation or a button you can click and
it will send you the top that's another
good option that's a good option as well
if a wonderful interior you I have
something like that built-in I know I've
done that on other sites I'm not sure
I've done it with the react site yet but
so I have some code that's probably
jQuery that we could maybe adapt to do
that or hopefully material I have
something like that left to see let me
know what y'all think is it better to
just have a button that sends you to the
top like a very small you know button
that would maybe pop up after you scroll
so far you know just just maybe in the
bottom right-hand corner it would pop up
or is it better to have that fixed
navbar that follows you all the way down
let's see John Henson says where make
just the hamburger fixed okay just the
hamburger icon that's interesting I
wonder how that would look
Stewart says just close the tabs okay
a noble and Savage is all right so if
you all remember whenever I was talking
about how I had all my tabs open and
it's easier just to search for something
like in my browser then they have to
find the tab that's open a noble site
and savage says inspects memory
footprint of browser your browsers using
5.3 gigabytes of RAM you laugh at that
but if I saw that I wouldn't be
surprised at all I think my browser is
always the using the most RAM out of
anything all right I'm gonna check I
only have a few more comments here in
the live chat so let me check out a few
of these comments before we go back to
the code
Michael D or G I'm not sure I pronounce
the last name there if you let me know
I'll try to pronounce it correctly but
anyway the question is I just started
using material UI version 1 I notice the
button element doesn't have an on-click
attribute so how do you trigger on click
events with a with buttons for Redux
actions etc how do i sorry
I'm always yawning on these streams I
really sorry you know what I'm not I'm
not really sure how I handle buttons
it's usually they got it you got to be
able to use one click with a button
right we had to have done this before
with something let me think about that
we may actually come across a button in
the stream today if anybody remembers
how we've handled buttons in previous
projects please put it in the live chat
because I know we've done stuff like
that before and we have use on click
things so I just can't remember right
now if we had any issues with that
uh-uh Ruben says the handsome comment
wasn't a joke you've got a good
phenotype I envy that beard
alright cool well thank you I appreciate
it and yeah well I just I got my beard
trimmed yesterday and I got a haircut so
it probably looks okay right now
normally it I let it go and it gets rid
of bushy and wild but right now it's
like looks slightly less wild but I said
I appreciate the comment though alright
so we do have some some other opinions
on this navbar so hmm it was the sticky
never would look a little nicer small
button fading as usuals down alright so
maybe we don't go with the fixed navbar
I'm getting getting some some opinions
against the the fixed navbar here
I wanted to see how this looks
oh okay so the fix and a bar also messed
up some stuff for us here so that was
unexpected all right let's go back here
and resort layout I don't know where yet
yeah this is what we did it let's go
back to static save that and verify that
this now works no what the heck oh you
know we changed some other stuff so
that's probably why it's not it's not
gonna work all right what else do we
change oh yeah so we're getting some
there's some more opinions about fixed
nav bars being annoying if they're too
thick yeah so we could make it thinner
or I'm I don't know I'm thinking now
maybe we could just avoid having to like
deal with this like cascade of issues
that we're seeing here if we just go
with that button that scroll to top
button this also seems like something
that could wait until after the
presentation so it's probably something
that doesn't need to be done right now
so I'll just keep in mind to try to find
a component that that'll give us that
scroll to top or some other solution but
I think I've got myself into like too
much stuff considering I have a
presentation tomorrow I think it's at
11:00 a.m. tomorrow what the heck is
this healing from why are we importing
healing that that stuff my mistake when
did that change
alright let me just go back
hidden there we go I accidentally
changed that so alright good
okay this is back to normal
alright so we're back to normal here we
are whoops
switch it to here we're right back where
we started and that is how do we make
this centered all right let me take a
drink and let's start over for all of
you that are new to the stream one of
the biggest features of this stream that
makes it stand out from other streams is
that I don't rehearse anything so
mistakes can and do happen often and
this is my everyday work so we worked
through the mistakes together I just
realized that I also forgot to start my
timer again so let's start the timer all
right now let's go back to this
all right so our mission is get this
logo centered on small screens what
we're not gonna do is change the we're
not we're doing to try to change as
little as possible in this app bar okay
ha ha Ruben says I heard centering
things is half the job of a front-end
dev it certainly seems like that today
doesn't it all right so let's go back to
our app bar component where we actually
have this and let's see what we can do
let's see if
let's see if we can add a set of media
queries to the classes that we're
already using that that change some of
the values that may work so here's what
we're gonna do the image itself
that's interesting it looks like the
link is only on the bottom half of this
let's see if that's correct hmm let's
let's open this up so I can actually see
all right yeah let's go to a new page
oh no that did work cool all right I'm
not worried about that anymore as I was
scrolling through here it looked like
the link tag would not work but it did
all right so let's start here and let's
see we probably already did this I don't
think ever actually went through
completely with what I was trying to do
all right let's see
Grimm says isn't center X s /sm MMD
large going to work on react alright
let's see
- this button okay
all right maybe this will work fishin
flex a line-item Center let's try this
justify Content Center awesome
okay so if we justify content Center and
then we take this and we could probably
justify content left didn't take us out
far enough you also need to make
display flex what is this
that we're still off we're slightly off
hmm all right let me have some
suggestions here in the live chat so
Nikki saying instead of justify content
use justify item on the thing itself
that's what I was looking for just try
item okay button
justify item
Grimm says I love this channel awesome
I'm glad to hear it
we had a question if I'm using bootstrap
reflects Bach flexbox Center works as
Center on the logo
John says you need to make 100% width or
stretch the content yeah now we need
Oh
all right this is where okay
so I don't need that justify items
that's what I thought it's not doing
anything anymore
okay all right Nikki says okay I think I
got I got it I think all right awesome
let's see what's what's happening here
uh-huh yes my boss just sent me an image
to use instead of that cute little puppy
cool it's a cool image all right awesome
so after we fix this I'm gonna put that
image in alright do you justify items
flex start on the hamburger container
okay uh neighbor container
and then on the locator this fan okay so
on this one will do justify items center
all right dad
that didn't do anything for me but it's
possible that I've changed too much
other stuff let me give it a refresh to
clear out anything else that I've done
oh wait sorry justify self okay I'm glad
that I caught that before I refreshed it
alright so just for self on
Center
all right still not all right I am gonna
refresh cuz I think I've changed too
much stuff and I can't remember what I
changed which is the danger of dev tools
for me it's actually it's good practice
for me to frequently put in what I've
done in dev tools into the actual code
and let's try this again
sorry Phoenix
Abhishek the bot got you I think for all
those emoji so don't worry about it just
I guess I guess the butt doesn't like
when you put that many emoji in alright
it's alright so Nikki let me try to put
in what you said before so on the
container which I'm assuming is the the
button then maybe I'm putting this in
the wrong in the wrong part but let's do
justify items like start and then on
this band justify self Center alright
yes so this is not working for me it's
possible that I'm putting it in the
wrong place though so is it supposed to
be both of them self oops
all right so on the button now I have
justified self flex start and then I
also on this pan I have justify self
Center and column one needs to be
display flex
all right so it looks like yeah we have
well if you mean this div on iki said it
doesn't work sorry for wasting time
don't worry about it it's not a waste of
time to try out different things alright
cool so let's keep trying I apologize if
this is getting boring or something but
I mean this is there's probably there's
using this just to see how how
frustrating it can be sometimes to try
to get something seemingly so simple to
work alright I'm gonna give it one more
shot with these different flex
properties before we go to actually
adjusting the markup
all right so jelly has a solution that
says it worked
so let's if you try my solution on the
logos parents pan position:absolute left
50% transform Saturday okay so the logos
parent
so let's here let me refresh to get rid
of everything we just did all right so
here's our logos parent and that's this
this I'm assuming what you mean the span
and not this 8x I'm gonna go with the
span and let's go with position:absolute
and left 50% and then transform
translate or translate negative 50% oh
it works nice alright let's check it out
here let's check out what it's done to
us on the larger view yeah so it's done
this so we're definitely gonna have to
put that into a media query but so we'll
figure out at what point we're dropping
this stuff so whatever point we're
dropping that stuff maybe we could do it
or even yeah maybe somewhere around
there so I'm guessing that's maybe like
the small media query all right cool
I like that it almost like it seems a
little weird you know that we're doing
this to Center it but my viewpoint is
this if it works then it's okay as long
as it's not causing some weird like
performance thing that's that's messed
up then I'm fine with that
if later on we find a solution that
seems like it's a little cleaner great
but right now I really like that it
works so let's go with that so let me go
over here and we'll find that space
which I believe that this is our class's
flex so let me all right good so we're
only using that once so I just want to
make sure you aren't gonna mess anything
else up so on our classes flex that's
where we're gonna put this this media
query and what did we do the other one
we use the media query somewhere else
already did we do it in the app bar a
bar menu item maybe we did it here no
that wasn't it
we didn't do it here did we
maybe we used it down here because we
are hiding some things down here okay
that hidden small and down that's it
okay so we use that but there is another
place where we use the media query let's
see okay you know what there's some
sandy keys asking how exactly that works
that it would probably a good idea to
describe what's going on here so alright
so we have this position:absolute so
it's it's taking it out of the flow of
you know this is a span that's coming
after this element right so we're having
trouble centering things like that
because it was always trying to center
within this area which always would be
off this is not taking into account the
whole area so when we do
position:absolute that takes it out of
the normal flow so now we're you know
the whole area is is being you know
considered here so within and once we do
that we can do this left 50% so let me
let me take off transform we've got one
at a time alright so position:absolute
gets us now out of the flow then we go
left 50% which actually doesn't look too
bad let's shrink it down so it can we
can see more so that means we're going
50% to the left but it's from this point
so this point is 50% over but that's not
taking to account the width of this
element right because we want the center
of this element to be 50% over that's
why we do transform translate 50% that
pushes the element over this way so
negative 50% right that pushes it over
half the width of this element which
then makes the center the very center of
this element if we can imagine a line
going right in the center of this logo
that centerline would line up exactly
with the center line of this whole app
bar right so if the site itself had a
center line now the logo center line
matches up so that's why we did that
translate negative 50 so
jillee correct me if I'm wrong on any of
that but that's that's basically how
this works so I really like I mean I
know everybody's using flexbox and grid
now but this solution is is really nice
I think like it makes sense I've
definitely used some stuff like that
before you know compared to a lot of
which you can do now with grid and
flexbox it seems like we shouldn't have
to go through all that but like the
logic is you know it does make sense and
and it definitely works so thanks again
Joey all right so where was okay we need
to actually do this but only for small
screens so I need to see let me check in
material UI documentation since I can't
find it in our code we need let's go to
CSS and J s and let's use there we are
theme breakpoints great let's pull this
out and we'll do let's go to that flex
element and we're gonna add in a theme
break point and let's try small I'm
assuming small as SM seems reasonable
and let's go now to display wow it's
given me
display absolute and then we're gonna go
left 50% and transform translate and
it's going to be negative 50%
alright let's save that see what we have
mm all right not exactly working out you
know because we still had that in dev
tools let's refresh in Syria
okay not working I messed up something
display what did I mess up
what did I mess up
make points down
did I set that opposite no it's work
working uh maybe this is something wrong
display no I put display instead of
position right position there we are
Oh John I see you you had that too and
Michael so hey Joey
haha everybody got that good job alright
so let's see where that breakpoint is
gonna hit great that's perfect we it's
not so flike fast so you're gonna have
some like a second where it it goes over
I'm not worried about that I mean if
anybody is doing this stuff like I am
then they're probably a developer so
they will understand awesome oh that's
so cool it works very cool a hover
height
Joey tags in caps and got banned for
five seconds from the from the but it's
fun that we have a bot in here now
all right so my timer just went up and
that's awesome just in time to get that
centered I'm gonna be honest I really
expected that we would get more done
today than just this Oh woah it happens
all right so let me look in the latch at
answer some questions and we'll see what
time it is after that maybe I'll put in
the new image maybe not we'll see see
how it goes all right where did I leave
off okay
maybe there's not a lot of question I'm
not finding a lot of questions here so
it might not be be too much more to talk
about in this train
all right here's a question so Pruthvi p
or you d hv i not sure to pronounce that
please correct me if i was wrong but
anyway the question is why is reacts so
useful i know what reuses components
like recyclerview and java i mean we can
simply copy and paste component code
again yeah you're right we can copy and
paste again but I think like in a bigger
like in a bigger app you don't want to
be copy and pasting a lot of stuff right
it saves you a lot of time and then you
know when you have everything split out
into components it's really nice to be
able to reuse them and it's not just
about copy and pasting I mean you can do
things like this where you know when we
do this list this is the list card
component we pass in an array right and
we map over the array items and we could
have you know 500 you know items and all
being being rendered and we only did
this one time so right now I have this
list data component so all the data
lives here you know in a JavaScript
array but we could this is just some
kind of test data for the presentation
tomorrow but we could be pulling this
from a database somewhere and send it
right in here and now from one component
we could have just rendered you know as
I said before 500 or whatever however
many you want so I think that's that
that makes it more clear about the
benefit of using components so maybe I'm
misunderstanding the question but
hopefully that makes it a bit more clear
you know you definitely wouldn't want to
actually put all of this data in and
then copy and paste this 500 times right
that would be it would be a lot of code
and it would take a long time and then
if somebody you needed to come in here
and make an edit
you know that'd be kind of a mess anyway
so that's as I see it that's one of the
benefits of using react and it's not
like other systems don't do this in
their own way it's not unique to react
but it's definitely ate a benefit
let's see the Johnny plays asks what
programming language is this
this is JavaScript in particular though
we're using react which is a JavaScript
library that it looks like a mix of HTML
and JavaScript it's not really this is
like some syntactic sugar
really it's JSX right I believe it's
called JSX when you
it looks like the HTML tags when reality
all this is or you know this is
JavaScript functions so each time you
see a tag like this really what's
happening is it's creating a new element
like you could do normally in JavaScript
San Bay says I like your radio do you
mean the the free coke amp radio that's
going on 24/7 now yeah it's pretty cool
if you all haven't checked it out yet I
mean I'm sure you've seen it on the
channel now we have this this radio
station and all the songs are created by
free code camp members I don't release
it members like it's not like we pay a
membership fee or anything but created
by by people who are in you know free
code camp so it's pretty cool check it
out and then there's a live chat going
on every time I've been in there there's
been at least like 20 people so it's
pretty cool like Quincy was in there for
a while talking so you never know who's
gonna pop in and talk so it's kind of
cool just to listen to while you're
doing other things throughout the day
Emerson says it's cool to know I'm not
alone when working with CSS yeah I mean
I personally like CSS but it can
definitely be tricky sometimes
almost to the end here
Gander 7 says I hate data import from
system with no validation were you
talking about the data I was just saying
when I was talking about bringing data
in yeah I mean right now I'm not worried
about it because this is just test stuff
but in general you would want to have
some validation I'm a little bit more
lenient with that when I have control
over all the data where it's coming from
so it's way less likely that we're gonna
get we use the OK gander 7 says notice
what I'm working on
ok cool cool all right
for some reason Google and my phone
keeps thinking that I'm talking to it
keeps like popping up saying it doesn't
recognize my voice it's just weird
but anyway all right I've gotten to the
end of the live chat I think I'm gonna
take a break now because I feel like I
need a break and so I'm not gonna put in
the the new image so maybe that'll be a
surprise for tomorrow that will unveil
the the new header image that are the
hero image so I have to say goodbye to
the cute puppy and and we'll have an
actual image of campus let's see oh ok
Jeff Miller says I know you're working
on the mobile look now but on a desktop
the navbar text is compacted together
all right let's take a look at that you
know what Jeff I'm not seeing it here
could you let me know
what browser and device you're looking
at that with and also the like the
browser version if you could so you can
just put it here in the in the chat even
if it's after the stream ends they'll
still be like a minute or two where you
can put it in the chat so maybe it's
maybe I'm we're using something that
doesn't work in all browsers Nietzsche
says put the puppy somewhere as an
easter egg
he's like a mascot by now I was just
thinking that as I was saying we're
gonna get rid of it I'm thinking like is
there a way to put images in the console
so that if somebody opens dev tools will
see it if there is I think I should
definitely do it all right
Jeff's astride an edge and Firefox okay
I'll have to test it we're definitely
gonna have to do some thorough testing
before this goes live I'm okay with not
testing it that much before the
presentation because I'm gonna be
displaying it from you know from my
computer and so it should be alright
I can control the environment but yeah
maybe we'll definitely have to figure
out what's going on there
all right thanks Jeff for pointing that
out and for testing it out and you know
various ways all right but anyway I
think we had a good stream it took
longer to do a little thing that I
thought it would but we worked through
it and that's always I mean that's a win
right even if it took longer that's a
win we got it to work it looks awesome
and you all helped a lot and 2008 yeah
happy Valentine's Day for everybody out
there also a happy beginning of Lent its
Ash Wednesday so for anybody that I
guess it's Catholic or even their non
Catholics I think that celebrate Lent I
think anyway
so in our day that we have both
happening on the same day but anyway
whatever you're celebrating today I hope
you have a great day and I'll see you
all back tomorrow hopefully hopefully my
meetings gonna don't go too long but I
should be back maybe around the same
time maybe out 1 p.m. Eastern time
tomorrow so I'll see you then